[Music]
good morning John it's Thursday April
5th I have some bad news
you said that I could visit my local
Hummer dealership and test drive a
Hummer this is one of the best ideas
that I've heard for punishment in a long
time and I'm very sorry to have to say
that I can't do it because I don't have
a local Hummer dealership the nearest
one is a hundred and fifty three miles
away and then I felt some hair salons to
see if they professionally watched my
chin but it turns out that professionals
don't wax chins the lady on the phone
said that it was a high blood supply
area they don't do it because of the
potential for permanent damage boy I'm
really sorry I made you do that
it's Brotherhood 2.0 is embarrassing
moment puppet theater oh oh that's
embarrassing my hair just fell off I
have a hurry Nick Oh her neck
embarrassing moment number one hello my
name is Justin and I was hangs a
roommate in college I have long hair and
a slight frame and one day I was minding
my own business eating some Marmite on
toast when Hank walked into the room oh
my look it's Catherine well what was
that huh embarrassing moment number two
I'm Katherine small so Katherine what am
I going to meet this Hank I've been
hearing so much about maybe when we get
back to campus after a grocery shopping
here I can't introduce you to him
together oh he's coming oh oh um hi
it's nice to meet you I'm Hank Oh
what a nice young man he ran into my
legs I decided that it would be cool if
I would slide off my knees down the
aisle at Albertson's and run into
Catherine but instead I ran into her mom
embarrassing moment number 3 what a nice
drive Sarah I have never dated a more
beautiful person than you and I never
will until I meet Catherine yeah you are
you look pretty awesome today too with
that black lipstick on yeah you're so
cool oh my god I totally forgot to get
gas oh my god what are we going to do I
know we'll walk to 7-eleven and call my
mom mom I ran out of gas and unstuck at
7-eleven can you come pick us up even
though it's like 2 o'clock in the
morning you ran out of gas
yeah it was pretty stupid I'll be there
in a minute but I am not happy with you
oh this sucks I'm so sorry
this is hello hi mom I'm really sorry
about this but I didn't know what else
to do stop talking what's on your face
what there is something on your face it
looks like you're wearing makeup can you
just draw it Sarah home sooner this
nightmare could be over you are so
grounded John is here har Oh